I have a great respect for the
origin of life, from the smallest
microorganisms to us. We can
sit here, we can talk, we breathe,
the heart beats fantastically
and I would like to be
able to preserve that without the
extinction of the breath
When biodiversity decreases, every
ecological niche has its purpose and
every species that dies out makes the power
worse, but I wouldn't be me
if I didn't believe that
up to now, at least, humans
have always managed to
pull themselves out of these difficult
situations that are affecting us  and so
I believe that
science research and development
can bring many solutions here in the future, but we
also have to tackle it.
Welcome to the OMR podcast from
Düsseldorf and a conversation that
I could never have imagined at the beginning of the podcast
because we
started after all  With marketing and really
core digital topics, we have now
really arrived in the big German
economy and you can see it
in today's podcast. Our guest is the
chairwoman and I would say
head of the Henkel shareholder group
Simone beltra hello greetings D Philip
hello hi thank you for yours  Time I've got it
before you've already noticed the pull OMR
times I'm very happy
about it yes it's an institution
now I have to say I've heard
one or two podcasts,
not all of them can do it of course who
can do it but I'm deeply
impressed  from the spectrum of guests
that you invite, from the topics
that are addressed and
I think there really is something for everyone and it's
nice that you have a lot of young listeners
because that's the future,
yes, but that's why I say that  a
little bit because the two of us don't meet in our normal
imagination,
you're a
studied or doctorate in
biology, um, and then you've been working
really intensively for almost 15 years now, so
tell me a
little bit about what the job is that you do  Now that's
exactly what you're doing,
so that's a big task.
Chairwoman of the
shareholders' committee of the
supervisory board and also spokesperson for the
family, which basically includes, as
you might imagine,
on the one hand the Henkel company and
also the Henkel family.
I
have to invest the majority of my time in the company  I say and
the management of the two committees is in the
foreground and of course I invest
a lot of time in talking to
the board here on site in
preparation with the members of the
committees and also preparing the
content that is relevant for us as a company
yes also say D
Henkel is already one of the largest
German companies in terms of
sales and market value and
your family includes around 200 people
so you could read that
60% still belong to Henkel no yes so
you can say that the family
exists
These
family members have pooled around 60% of the
voting common shares in a
so-called share binding agreement
and that is the instrument
through which the family can also contribute
to the company in the form of governance issues,
okay but still if
you do a job like that  you
first have to understand the company well,
so what you do are certainly
demanding things, so say something yourself
when you introduce Henkel yourself, what do
you say about the company? Yes, of
course you can answer that very formally
by saying Henkel is
global  operating company we
make around 20 billion euros or a good
20 billion euros in sales we have
activities worldwide with around 50,000
employees in 180 countries and we
have two large corporate divisions,
one is a consumer business
hkel consumer brands which content is
primarily detergents and cleaning products
and  the area of ​​hair and body care
and at the same time we have a
company of approximately the same size, adhesive
technologies, which
deals with industrial businesses and supplies very different industries in the areas of adhesives, sealing
and coating,
so I also
read the automotive industry in a more descriptive way when I try to do that now
to
answer then I would say
your day may have started like that
or to describe where Henkel appears over the course
of the day in the shower
you may have showered with one of our
products or
washed your hair say drop R
times pa Brand Schauma is  Very well known,
we have Gliss as a brand
fahduschgeleele.
If you
look at your smartphone for the first time then it is
very likely that it was
put together with Henkel adhesives. You go into the
kitchen, open the fridge.
White goods are also an industry that Henkel
supplies  Putting the
components together you might make a
muesli with milk and muesli and also
because there are Henkel products in flexible packaging
you might travel
to your work by bus or car mobility
and cars is a large area that
Henkel supplies there are also
on average in every car  x
Applications included you arrive in
your office another branch of the
industrial business is also construction there are also
joints
leveling compounds so many topics
within house construction are relevant you
look at your PC display digital
worlds Henke also supplies a
lot of manufacturers when they arrive at home
you might put your laundry in the
washing machine and use Persil or
the white giant or Spee to
clean the laundry and after
dinner you might want to
rinse your things with priil or with Somat
to fill the dishwasher and that's
pretty much in the different worlds
Henkel is at home and meets
its customers all over the
world okay and when I
asked myself how deep can you
get into it now as someone who
of course didn't found this company SN
you are now the fifth generation  No,
but in the end it
's somehow responsible for everything. What do
you understand now, hard question about all
these things, yes, it's a
good question. I'm extremely enthusiastic about Henkel. That's all
I can say: I generally think it's
a really nice
company when I go through here in the morning
I'm happy every time I come to the factory gate
because I can still learn something every day.
Of course, I don't know everything and
of course, as chairman
of the supervisory board, I don't have to
know every detail, but over
the years I've of course gained a lot of insight
through many conversations
Reading and you get a
very good overview and for
the chemical work at the end it is relevant
that you ask the right questions and pick out the
topics that are of great importance for the future of the
company
and of course we have a board of directors who are
operationally responsible for the management of the
company  is responsible and who,
operationally, is of course much deeper into the
issues than I am or
the other members of the supervisory board or
shareholder committees are. It has
become particularly clear that I am
currently reading the new biography about Elon Musk.
Have you already noticed it or
so I have noticed it?  I've
read the old one, I have
n't yet, what's really crazy about it,
I'm fine with how deeply he himself
is involved in all of his things, both the
rockets and the cars, and then there are
some questions of a
technical nature at a totally low
level  Now let's take this this
ventilation this ventilation this costs so and
so much and it costs so and so much
then he says okay we'll take it and he
's totally there himself and I think
okay so that's the only way it can actually work
if someone says  Okay, I have the
responsibility, I'm the
main shareholder there and I
also know what I'm doing, so I do it
that way and that's often the case with
such big companies when you have to take it over
and you haven't built it yourself, it's
possible  That's also a disadvantage
or I think it depends on the
distribution of roles,
so if you're the entrepreneur yourself,
like Fritz Henkel, the gentleman who stands behind me,
he of course has a lot of everything
and everyone, it's his
business and it's also
manageable  big at the very beginning at the
time of founding my small
company, which I co-founded 20 years ago,
I was able to do everything. A
distribution of roles in such a large
company is very important and that's why I understand that it's
not my job to be
able to answer all of these detailed questions  My job is much
more to ask the right questions
and say if we are going to make
this or that investment project
or set up a production facility, what are the advantages
and disadvantages, why should this
be at this point, what other
GT options, perhaps what is, how expensive, how
long does it last  what are new
technologies that you
really get to grips with in a context
and look at
the matter from many perspectives
and put it on the table and
then discuss it with the experts and
of course it depends on the topic
whether and to what extent I am involved  Because I'm deeply
involved or the other
members of the committee, some topics
are suitable for this, some are
of course favorite topics, so I
studied microbiology for my doctorate
and there are already some interfaces, there
aren't many in the details but
when it comes to detergents and enzymes
I can do that  very good to have a say,
probably to the chagrin of
the manager. Actually,
people are happy when you
are interested and so on and
can understand and classify things. What was
the toughest decision for you in all these years? Say,
okay, Bo  Now something really has to be
decided which is difficult
or and of course with a certain amount of
uncertainty or where were you at what
was the biggest impact and the most
uncertainty so that the
hardest was your your formulation was
certainly the decision on
Russia that was incredibly difficult
a billion  Russia made
around a billion in sales in
Russia, so everyone knows the context.
Russia
invaded Ukraine and this raised the question for us,
as for many companies that
are or were active in the region,
how do we deal with this context
and we had both  In Russia
sales employees production facilities
than we also have in Ukraine to a
smaller extent and
for this question do we stay in Russia
or do we leave the country, we had to
weigh up a lot of aspects and the
difficulty was that
no matter what decision we
made  It would be a bad decision
to stay in the country, it would be
bad to leave the country, it would be
bad and in this respect the deviation of
the individual perspectives under
time pressure under constantly
changing
basic requirements was the situation on site
changed very quickly, the
environment has changed  The view
of this conflict is fluid because it's
clear at some point that we're going to do
it now, it took a lot of effort from everyone.
I can't say that any other way
because that's a story that we
have there, we were in the country for over 30 years,
we had responsibility  For 2,500
Henkel employees, we had a lot of
production sites and giving that up was
just emotionally painful.
We said it was
the right decision for Henkel and at this point in time. There
was still criticism
that it took longer than we
would have liked, it would have been
even faster  supposedly or
wishfully can happen but
you or she still have to give an interview
that doesn't happen that quickly you
have to look at it first somehow if
you leave something there you can't
just say from this morning we're
out now no yes and that's the way it is  I too
can understand that there is impatience,
but if you look into
the matter a little,
you quickly realize that you
have to weigh up a lot of things and take responsibility for each of these
partial decisions
and that's why it was
time well spent and this accusation
Henkel hesitated, I
actually can't understand it or
understand it because we have so many
activities on site, other
companies may only have a few
stores and and or only one office and
and a few employees and a
decision is made to say we're
withdrawing  Then you terminate a
rental agreement and move your
employees away. That was
n't possible for us and that's why the
decision took a long time and
then the implementation, as you've
seen. In the end, I have to say,
the management here is our board of directors  did an
excellent job, super
serious, extremely professional and brought it
to a very good end under the given conditions. It
's also difficult for you
to select the right board members. I
mean, you have to fill them from time to time. That
's the job of the
supervisory board  No, yes, that is one of the
most important tasks, that you have the
right
management personnel
in the company, because in the end they are
the ones who have extreme influence
on how the company
is continued, what is the right
strategy, how should the
company divisions be expanded,
how  Let's make the company future
and competitive and you need
the right heads and
of course it's not just a matter of the
heads being the right ones individually, but
in the end they have to be able to work together as a team
and how do you think so
in the end it's up to you  you call a
personnel consultancy and say, man, we
need a
department head or even a
CEO again and then suggestions come in,
you look at five people and you say
okay, I have the best feeling, so
you are the final filter or yes, how do
you do it?  That's - first of all,
I have to say, you always talk about me
and that's completely fine as a representative of these
committees, but
of course there are several of us and
I'm extremely grateful that these
important decisions
are team decisions and that's why
this diversity is there  Teams are important
because different aspects play a role.
Who is the right
man or woman when it comes to appointing
a board member
and the process of who is the right one and
how do we get to the right one
can take different paths?
Either you are in the  Situation in-house
through your own very good preparation and
succession planning always build pipelines
that ensure at any time
that you either
build up people in the long term or even if
something unexpected happens, you
always have plan B in your own house - that's
a good, very good option like me  find
and should primarily be possible
then at the same time there are always
situations in which it is good
to look for someone from outside and
then working with
personnel consultancies is actually a very
good way, they have a very good
overview of international
managers and can make pre-selections and
recommendations  At the end of the meeting,
discussions are held
and you then try
to select those people on a shortlist
who actually fit in with Henkel here
because that is also a very
important point in my opinion - it is
not enough just to have had a
good career and achieved great results somewhere else  In
the end, it also depends on
whether the person fits into the
corporate environment, fits into the
corporate culture, yes, and um, then you
can also use this second
variant described to search externally,
of course, also board members g
a kind of gut feeling D such a sensor that you
have built up over the years or  you
as a team or I mean they do
n't do any tests at an
airport like that SN you have to have
a sensory system somehow in the conversation I think okay
now that's one person who would
fit yeah um so in the end it's a
decision of several members
Of course, depending on the position, our shareholders' committee
also includes members of the board of directors in
such selections because they
are future colleagues and
experience over the years helps.
Of course,
many people are able to present themselves
excellently in a conversation,
the question then becomes  what
's left of it in day-to-day and
operational terms and that's
why gut feeling is also
incredibly important to feel, it fits,
it fits in the end for both sides and
how far are you committed to such a tradition here,
so you could also
argue, for example  such a large
company with such different things,
why is it even a company? You
could also end up saying that there are
now perhaps two, i.e.
the whole industry application of
adhesives and the B2C application
with detergents, which is already very
far away from each other  Is something like that
inviolable or or do you
think about it?
Nothing should actually
be inviolable
for me for the congratulations for the board of
directors and all shareholders, the
most important heading at the top should be
how do we keep the
company competitive and
future-proof and the answers  The results
can be different and the
question you asked is about
the structure and there may be times
when structural questions can be decided one way or the other.
I think that
's a bit of an academic
question or sometimes fashion whether
you say we filter and
portfolio companies turn into pure
players and then there are phases in which
exactly the opposite happens again. We
come from the tradition of
having many activities under one roof. For
us, this has always been a good
positioning so far because it has made it possible to do so even
in times of crisis  There
are phases in
which our industrial business
is a bit more cyclical and perhaps
not going well and the
consumer sector is stable and the
other way around it can also be that there
are phases in which the
consumer business is shaken and
the
industrial sector has good, solid, stable
development  shows that this enables us as a
group to build up a high level of resilience overall,
for us it is of course also
an option
that a
large spread of asset allocation
can happen within one company, so we have
now
set up activities all over the world, an originally
German detergent business is
now  international and
not just a detergent business
but active in various divisions.
Another advantage we see
is that due to this size we
have a higher balance sheet and you
can make larger acquisitions
if you want and of course
there are synergies between
business areas in the areas  that are
relevant for both, for example the HR
for legel for finance, we have built up synergistically effective services for
both
areas of the company,
if
you will, but I think you can tell that
a bit of tradition is
somehow something that obliges you a
bit  My now
fifth generation, I
somehow always
know these watch advertisements where you
supposedly never own a watch like that
but only keep it for the next
generation. That's a bit
like your motto in life, especially with the company,
so as I said, you should pay attention to it  Make sure
that the company is fit for the future.
In our family we have this
satzfma that has really been shaped over decades and the
past has shown that we
are quite capable
of making decisions that perhaps
go against this tradition, i.e. a
primordial cell of the company  There were
chemical businesses and chemical activities
that we then spun off and
sold because we said we
were no longer the best owner for
these activities and so I believe
it is our job today, that of the
current generation,
to manage the company in such a way that it is  is future-proof and
you shouldn't rule anything out. You
should never basically say that one
or the other is out of the
question because, as we all
know, times are extremely volatile and
so much is happening outside, so
of course you have to anticipate what
position we as Henkel are in
Well prepared for the future you have
somehow adopted an
unusual approach in that you
still have 60% as a family, that's
not really all that rational if you look at it soberly,
you would say that's
too much  I would like to commit a lot of assets to one or, in this case,
two companies. I could
also somehow sell off part of it and
then go into real estate around the world or
into other companies. That's
not a plan, but rather it is now being
expanded, so the family share
has grown in the last few years
It's true that this
family is fully behind the company.
We may have many heads, but what unites
us all is an incredible
pride in the company, in this
founding story and, even after 177
years, in still having a setting in which
the family is one  Playing such a role
is a value in itself, so having
the assets bundled together as a family in one
company enables, on the
one hand, entrepreneurial participation,
which is important for many, that we say
we are continuing the legacy of the founder
and and do that in in  the
format in which Henkel exists today Fritz
Henkel may have started things differently,
but many of his values, many of
his ideas, this founding spirit,
a lot of it is still there and we would like to
continue that and in addition to this
large participation that we all have,
we also have a  Family life
and that too is a certain
added value. We all like to come
together several times a year to
discuss business matters with each other. That is the core of
most events, but the
surroundings are considered to be just as valuable.
You have to say that's quite
spectacular  So you control that
too, I've read a bit
about it and I think there's
even an Inter Intranet platform
for the family, so for these 200
people there's a youth club
lion club or something like that where the
younger ones can go on vacation somehow  There's
Hal, this
get together as a family, there's a
magazine of its own, I think it's called face,
I read it where you
somehow get informed and
even make a magazine, so there
's a lot of work in it,
just this family  To people, that's exactly how
it is, so a lot of my
time goes into family and
I can say that I'm not alone,
fortunately, we have a lot of
family members who are involved
on a voluntary basis and
invest time in maintaining this family
and that's the starting point  Certainly the
joint participation in the company
and many of our events
also have
company shares, but it is also
incredibly important to let this familial
togetherness live and
demonstrate it and also fill it with content.
You need structures
for that, you need a very good
organization and fortunately we have that  Of course,
this family governance
also has to grow with us because we are
constantly getting bigger because the family is also becoming
more international. Not everyone was born in Germany, of course, and not everyone speaks
German in their first language, oh
really okay and
that is still my claim to be met in some way if possible
When I
send out invitations, I am happy about
everyone who is hesitant. Some live further away
or of course have completely different paths
in life, so not everyone comes to
every event, but we have a
great gentleman who is very active here. It
is also important to involve the
next generation  We are
very active there, as you
said earlier, we have our lion club
and many other events throughout
the year, all actually with the idea
that we want to involve the next generation at an early stage and get to
know what it's about and what
it's about and that's just it  In
two ways, it's about family
and at some point it's also
about the company and as a young
family member, I think it's
initially important
to state that I have a family, I
have cousins ​​here and we
get along well and that's why there are
events that actually only
for for network and families and and
and fun just know everyone personally yes
the Ken I all personally that hot you
have D also probably every
other day congratulations birthdays and
stuff like that everything is full so
I can manage the round and special
birthdays yes the the  I write
but I can't congratulate everyone every time.
That would actually be too much
work, but for those who
turn 18 or have a big birthday
today I'll also write one.
I already know W birthday today please
W birthday today yes I'll leave that alone
like, it's okay, how did you
get into this, why are you allowed to or why do
you have to represent this family anyway,
so is it somehow
a job that you would like to do
or that you had to be persuaded to do
than there are of course still sorry
about that but  Tell me for yourself, I mean
that's actually W you
think about it, the shares are
distributed relatively equally, so from a distance you
can see there are some people in
Australia in the USA and they think it's super
cool, I get a dividend too
and Simone  Do it in
Düsseldorf and you have to do the work,
it's a lot of work, but I really
enjoy it. For me, it's
really a great job
to invest my life time in making sure
that this family stays together. For
us, this value is: we are one,
we  Speaking with one voice is the
greatest asset we have and that's why
I really like to see
that it stays that way and
I didn't have to be persuaded too much.
I think that's part of this
job and that's part of the
appeal  the fact that you
have major shareholders that you know and who
remain on board in a binding manner, it's
a matter of give and take and your
starting point was completely correct to
say, actually anyone who is
currently a member of the share binding agreement could
also say why should it
actually be me?  My shares are
freely tradable on the stock exchange, so I know
much better what I
want to do with them so that this doesn't happen
but so that everyone says, man, Henkel
is really a great investment and
my assets are well kept there and
are well developed. I can do that
Continuing the tradition of our family company and I still have a
family, a large family and top with a
lot of values, that's what I invest my
time in and that's what I like to do  So it
took a
long time for years and at some point he
realized that Simone could do that, it
's a little bit connected to the role
because my predecessor in
this role, chairman of the
committee, supervisory board, was also the spokesman for the
family, so that was
the setup  nothing changed at all the question
why did I become this or how did
I become this there was an excellently
organized process behind it my
predecessor together with other
representatives of his generation
thought about early on how this should and
when should this
actually happen with a generational change
and has  then over several years and a
really well-
orchestrated process that
led to the fact that in the end several
people could have made it from
my generation,
but in these years we met several times, that was
actually the special added value,
there was a
group of potential  Successors
plus a group of members of
our generation who perhaps
cannot or do not want to take on this role themselves
but who
are incredibly important as multipliers because
my predecessor rightly said that
in the end one of you will do it, but
you will not do it alone
You need a ring of
amplifiers of confidants who
also act as a multiplier in the company and family
and I think that
was a really great experience for
all of us who were involved in developing
a great deal of trust
with one another over the years  To
build a sense of togetherness and at the end to actually
say okay, someone will do it now
but it is clear that it is a
common task for all of us but it is also a
job in the end you will also be paid for the job
I assume yes, um, all of them with
members of the shareholders' committee
and the supervisory board receive salaries, as is
normal for DAX companies, so do I, and as
chairman you get more than a
normal member because in fact, even
with preparation, you have more arit, a
number of things to think about. You are now
also public  yes, when you
read about Henkel or in general there are
various
groups of wealthy
people and people who are into anwung in Germany,
the name always comes
up and that of the
other 150,200 people just doesn't yes and
that's it  Somehow you have to
want it somehow and it
seems to me that
the question is actually why do you want that if you do? It
's almost unfair, the SIT is there
somewhere and you're doing the work for them
against that, comparatively yes,
fair, of course, but with reference to  Overall,
small
supervisory board salary or something like that, so
dealing with the
public and the pressure that comes with it, that
's part of the job
and you learn that over
time. I would say that I
may have underestimated that at the beginning,
or  I didn't expect it that way. You have
to say that
's true, but the mere
fact that a woman in this role
followed her sausages is relatively
young and unknown, that has already
attracted a lot of attention and that is it
Over the course of the first few years,
you have to
say I come from a time in which
my parents were divorced.
I grew up with my mother.
I didn't know at a young
age that I belonged to this family,
nor did my school friends, nor the teachers
It was a wonderful, anonymous
growing up, yes, that's exactly what it was,
in retrospect, a great
gift because I did
n't bother with it or stress about it at all or I was
n't conceited about it,
um and that's completely
different
now. Now the face is often in  the
newspaper even without me being asked for it
because a picture is simply placed in some rankings
or reporting.
That
's something you have to live with. That's not
always pleasant. I do
n't actually need that. I
try to give targeted interviews,
but I don't want to  a lot because, as I said,
the management
of the company is basically the responsibility of the board of directors and
in most cases they should
also represent this. Every now and then there are topics
that are relevant for the supervisory board or
shareholders' committee,
long-term perspective and the like
then it's my part  I
admit I'm also a regular reader of
all these lists and recently
also with the manager magazine e.g. they
also make a list a podcast
closed and then I've
thought about it again
so to speak in really I
hope that I'm there  Now don't
come across as too strange but
in defense of the situation for
actually because these lists are just
so hard and if you
now or I'll tell you how I
see it and you say that
's complete nonsense but if you share these
If you just want to keep the company over the next
generation,
then they are not really tangible for you
as assets
because you hold them and now
only a
dividend comes out, and
I have now read the dividend, it comes D like that  800
million somehow a year, you then have to
pay taxes on it and then there are 200
recipients, that is, then
I don't know, taxes come before taxes then if it is
distributed about the same 4 million per
capita to the people, that's
for such a super rich list
Relatively little money, you get
more money a year playing in the Bundesliga than
4 million somehow V before taxes, which
you then get there as a diver, now
you get empty and top so you do
n't have to worry, but
at least it's not that ultra rich now  how
you think now, okay, Elon Musk, he
just sells shares there, shares
back and forth, that's a
difference,
yes, that
's too fair, no, I think
that's a very
refreshing look at
these rankings and lists, now
your calculation is the one  You're
not quite right because the 800
million that Henkel
pays out every year is of course not only
100% to the family company, okay, that's
100% dividend that has to be shared by all shareholders
and we have ordinary
shares and preference shares, all shareholders
receive dividends and the family also receives them
The 60% mentioned, that's just
the 60% of the common shares okay okay okay
so in this respect Kiner is the
number of dividends to be distributed
to the family is even smaller than you
just mentioned
and I also think that's important when
looking at it  Second, what you
said is the assets that appear in the
lists are derived from
the stock market price that we currently have and
is also a correct number,
but if you look out here in
Bri and m in production facilities and the
company is something that we  I just
want to keep it, it's not a
fungible asset, but the answer applies
or is just as correct for many
others who are on the list. There is a
big difference, there are some
who have the cash, so they really have it
now somehow we don't
belong to the fir  100% a smaller company
and then toes who own the total as
individuals, partly that's a
huge difference no, I mean to say
it's not fungible because we've all
signed, we're keeping our
shares, so the number is
correct but it's not like that  that
you can then
buy something else with it tomorrow, but we just
said we'll keep the shares in
the company and what else
might be important to know or
consider in the lists is, in my opinion, these are
families that are listed and it
But there are big differences whether it
is a small family, the whole
company belongs to a few people, there are also
examples and as is the case with us
where there are an incredible number of
family members, the
number of billions that is there has
to be divided again by  the number of heads
and there are also big differences, yes,
and now there is often only one name
that represents a large family and
I don't actually need that either
and it would be nice if it doesn't
have to be felt, we can do it again here,
I think  a little bit of light and
then it is always mentioned, yes,
you are afraid of kidnapping, yes,
one thing is of course a safety aspect,
but I also think it is relevant for the
upbringing of children. Well, as I
said before, I thought it would be nice to
grow up anonymously  That was a
big advantage because you
are completely unburdened. Those who are on
this list have the responsibility
to raise and raise society in the future and to
educate them so that they
become sensible business leaders and I think
it is so important that you as  young
person who grows up and
wants to take his own life into his own hands,
that you have goals, that you think about what
I want to do with it and don't
see at an early age that
I actually don't need to do anything, just look at what's
already there  in the
newspaper and that's disillusioning
for a young person, so for a
lot of people, I can imagine you
actually had your own
company yourself, you haven't even
noticed it yet, so it still exists
at some point, yes, it still exists  It's
really a very small company and I
also enjoyed doing it very much,
that's what I learned and
that was also my life plan and blueprint for
my career number one. Things have
turned out differently now and I don't need that
either  Of course, that's
why I was able to invest a lot less time in my own company.
Thankfully, I always had a
partner who was co-managing director and
he also had more shares than I did
afterwards and he also bore the brunt of
the operational side. I have to say
yes and how did you  Learned business administration,
I mean, you're a biologist, of course, a
natural scientist, you're
probably already smart, but
you should have done all these business administration topics in NBA or you didn't
do that, yes, I was learning by doing,
so starting my own company was
a very good school and I did that  I went
through a lot of what happens here in a big way in a very small way, so
taking out loans, renting property, hiring
staff,
making cost estimates, then delivering work,
writing invoices, and on, on, on, on, I have to
constantly plan and
I'll earn enough money to support my
employees and the  Paying wages and
also the rent, it was a good school,
I can't say it any other way,
and that's not the stuff that
a CFO has here in the house,
I don't bring that with me, that's very
clear, but I think it's okay there too  It's
not a bad idea to have the bigger picture, that you've already experienced it firsthand. You can
actually exchange a lot with other people
in your situation, now in Germany
or worldwide. I mean, that's
a special role, so it's
a responsibility  to take over
and get a company like that
somehow, so to speak, yes, I do that,
I do that regularly, I also really
enjoy it, both nationally and
internationally. I find it enormously
enriching to exchange ideas about these topics. There
are so many
successful and very different
examples  how family businesses can be
successful even over several generations still good so put it
like this where you say independent whether you
know now or not so where do
you see that S do it well there
are big and small so I
think family measure is one that is
very  successful because the mask is
a measure of the of the of the of the of the measure of
sweets exactly yes they have
changed a lot but one is super
interesting and and very successful in
my opinion but there are also
others who sometimes face challenges  There are
GTs that have to be mastered,
there are ups and downs and
I don't know if I'd be doing myself
the favor of mentioning their names,
but there are also
really great examples internationally
that manage to keep large numbers of
family members together over a long period of time
Even in phases when
things are difficult, i.e. representatives of the
automotive industry, for example, there are also some
families who work there in
Europe who have had to
jump over some hurdles in the last few
years and decades and but then you
meet like that, you get to
know each other or something  is then go to
the W and you meet the W or
or where is the where is the
hub
for this is a good mix of
either
organized events
that are actually designed primarily or
exclusively for family businesses
and that also exists
nationally and internationally  as well as
activities that have arisen independently of it, so you can also
meet people yourself. If I
travel somehow, then I make an
appointment. Sometimes I have an idea
and go there specifically for that reason or have
conversations, but there are now
also good platforms. The forum is for
For example, I don't know if
you
know that, there are two very
young entrepreneurs here from Germany,
paudiz and Tim Tiller, who set it up
about 15 years ago with the
idea of ​​bringing German-speaking
family entrepreneurs to the Middle East
and then they  brought together with
families from the area
and so the first
event was in Jordan in Oman and
it was great because you were immersed in a completely different
world and got to know a mixture
of business context but also
family context in a completely
different flir.
This platform is now bigger  have
become very successful and these
ties have built up a large network across the Middle East to the
USA to India to Asia in
Europe and this
is an excellent platform for
exchanging ideas on such topics, for example.
Two German guys have built it as a
business model, so to speak
then basically services and
you say okay, that sounds very
relaxing, exactly okay, okay, I ca
n't do it yet, um, and then it's
also the case if someone wants to sell shares
with you in order to complete this with the family,
so because that
's also there  You can read a little about
who belongs to the family,
it's possible, there are also very
different people, some
winemakers and artists and
real estate developers and so across
the board who are part of your family,
obviously if then but on
the one hand I need
some money because I have it  somehow
problem h then he wants to sell then
he can and then i catches it but that
means then somehow there is
a mechanism where
the family share doesn't
go down immediately but where he then sells it on the
stock exchange but then the
family shares, so to speak  anyway, or at
least the share is somehow
retained, so we have this
share agreement which of course
assumes that everyone
should normally be together and that
works really well.
I can't say that any other way. I'm
very proud of the family for the first
proper termination option  That
would be in 2033 and, as with any
good contract, it must of course
be provided that there will be
extraordinary occasions and so
we also said that
if someone really has an emergency, they must be
able to sell parts of their
assets
beforehand and for that  We have
constructed different cases and
different processes that then take place,
always with the idea that the shares to be sold are first
offered to our shareholders,
then within our own
tribe or then in the other tribes
in order to keep it in this pool as much as possible
So in that sense it will
stay that way for the next few years,
you already know ABS how long you'll
be doing the job in this
form, so it's a great
responsibility, I like doing it and
as I said, I'm still learning something about it every day, but of
course it's still one  It's a big
responsibility and I've been doing it for
a while now, so at
some point it's the right time for
the next one to come.
We've always
prepared very well over the years without any time
pressure and with a good process
like the last one  That's why
it will certainly be the same this time.
ST not at the door tomorrow.
No, next year there will be
elections and new elections scheduled for all committees in our company and
I, like the others, will be
on the ballot again  Okay, okay, how
do you look at
the world in general? I mean, I've read,
for example, it's also important that you
live in Düsseldorf if you
represent the form you have here, hey,
you're now very Germany-
centered here, the company is active globally
GZ have already talked a bit about Russia, there
are a few other
risks that are constantly being talked about,
especially for Germany for
Europe W you take a bit of a long-term view,
are you now more bullish
or are you saying to yourself that we are well
diversified anyway, that's on  In the end, it doesn't matter
how you look at
it, I could now give a lot of answers
to it, really on
different levels, maybe F
times in Germany. Of course,
I find the situation difficult at the moment. I'm
basically an
optimistic person, but I would
We would like a lot more for the country, we would need
a lot less bureaucracy, we
need more speed, we
need progress in education, in
digitalization, in so many topics
and it all takes a very long time here and
I think we had a really
great competition and
location advantage here  But
we can't put that at risk
and that's where I'm
worried. Then we have the great luxury
of saying yes, we're not just in
Germany, we're also
active more globally and Europe offers a
certain buffer because of that  because
other countries are sometimes better than
us, at least perhaps for
the economic forecast for this or
next year, but music
certainly plays in the regions where there
is even more growth than
perhaps in the established markets, which is
also partly the case for our products
China is a very relevant market for us
and of course we are noticing
at the moment that there are issues in the country
that no
longer make economic growth look as rosy as it did
a few years ago and are still there
Like many others, we are represented in the country
and as long as we
can generate growth there, as long as
we have customers who will
incorporate ours, as is the
case with technologies, we would
of course like to benefit from it and
at the same time you have to prepare yourself so
that you don't  depends only on one
country and this is also a topic
that we, of course, like all other
large companies that are represented there,
deal with, but that means that
you are probably
a little closer to it now than just
reading the newspaper or something
Since FST you talk to your
management V you talk to other families
who are active there, so that's a
big risk, so if
something really happens in China now you would have to
withdraw from there, which for you I think is
significantly more than the
billion in  Russia no, that's
bigger, yes, that's twice Russia,
roughly, and what's important is that you
try to map all of these eventualities
in advance, how well you'll
succeed, then it's
always the question, our management was
n't in either  the situation to travel for the last few
years because the trips there
were extremely limited, but
now it's working again and
I think that's extremely important in order to
maintain the ties in the country
with your own employees, extremely
relevant because they are under the
Corona  The topic
has also suffered a lot, but at the same time
you of course have to be there to
see how the country has changed,
how the competition has changed,
what actually happened during that time
and those who come back are
already saying how impressed they are
At the time in China everything was still
being set up, so the competition was
n't sleeping during that
time but was very
active. My feeling is that if you want to get
hold of a company like that in some way, then you also have to
talk to customers, so
you also have to talk to them  Customers as
not an end customer but
neighbors or friends with the
major customers so you go there yourself
and I mean without talking to customers
you can hardly estimate a company's
turnover
so yes and
no I have traveled with many of them in front of boards of directors
before the corona period and
part of the agenda on site was
often customer discussions, although for me
I am not a board member to repeat that again
and also the board
itself that meets the customers, which
is the case with selected customers
when they are  We also
bring in a certain amount of volume, but even members of the board
cannot meet every single one of our
customers. Nevertheless, there are
always opportunities for me to speak to
representatives of the retail sector, for example,
because we also
meet at congresses and events
and that is always important
I think it's exactly like you said, in order to
reflect on the other perspective, how does he see us, what
can we perhaps
do better? I mean, you're already asking yourself
when I imagine
this responsibility that you have in your schools
and at the same time this lump
that you have, so the majority of your
assets are now obviously in the
company,
um
then you want to understand whether this
lump is now so safe or unsafe
and in spite of everything, in China it is
difficult to say what is happening now
I assume that despite all the
discussions, no one really knows what's
coming and no one in Russia saw it
coming,
so how do you make this lump
a little more tangible because
you're also diversifying a
little bit? There's a Henkel Family
Office, I think  I don't think so, you're already doing
something, you can say something about it, maybe so, yes,
the hle family office, which we
set up ourselves many years ago.
We were faced with the question, do we need
it at all and if so, which
services do we
actually want to establish there and then have them?
Family members were asked and a
questionnaire was carried out. From the
feedback it was clear what
the family's primary requirements
were. We then set up something like this.
Not all family members take
part, so that's optional. If you
want, you can become a customer and have
your free assets managed there
It's tied up anyway
and
it works very well in that respect that you
can invest in other areas and diversify very well with
professional companies, so there is a larger
investment in my opinion so far at
Bayer, for example, also
on the chemical company here  If
you're from the Rhineland, you're also a major
shareholder or are you making other
investments that are worth mentioning to
you? And that's a lot of fun,
if I may say so, because you
can of course be involved in such an entrepreneurial way. There are
three people from the family who are
there  with the board at the Henkel
Family Office and and particularly
close to it, I as a customer can also
go and say, so pay attention, I
would like to invest my money in topics XY
and one of my topics was
sustainability and that is a
broad and big one  Term and in order to make this
a little more practical and implementable,
I said I would
like to invest in CO2 avoidance
topics, please look for
investment opportunities for me where the
good could be addressed and from
this this germ cell of the idea
several options emerged. One
was  Particularly interesting,
other family members were asked besides me
and so a nice sum came
together that was invested in a
company that
now has
CO2-free energy through the development of windpks and that is one of the ones
you know that is one of the larger companies.
I think I should now  you know
it's a big fund that
we've invested but I think I do
n't have any names here now,
people have podcasts and stuff like that, so it's
a big international, very well-known,
successful one, okay, and beyond that,
I mean, that's it  So my
next topic was a
the slightly different investments and B
I'm already out of it a bit
so responsibility that you now
have because you're in this situation that
you're in so it's not really great
but you're always in it  If you have access
to financial opportunities,
you definitely have a special
responsibility and
I think you have that as an individual and
as part of this family and also
with the leverage of the company. I think that you
should think about it for yourself
in the world for a certain
time and what do
I do with this time and what do
I perhaps want to leave behind, what
opportunities or wishes do I have to generate
some kind of influence here or in the
influence and you can do that
if you have wealth, of course it's better
or of course it's not  That's right, but
maybe it's easier than some
others when you
get together as a family. The
basics are perhaps even greater to
implement something like that and in the company
you of course have completely different levers, what do
I mean by the topic of sustainability?  As
already mentioned, I think it's
incredibly important and that
perhaps starts with the personal
attitude of saying I lead my
life one way or another and I want to
initiate changes here or there and
you can do that and with that you also have
an influence and I think so too
very important, what do you do
exactly? Example of what you do, it starts
very simply at home with your
energy contract that you have that you
use renewable energy, how
long and how hot do I shower, how do
I do my laundry,
a great topic I'll come to  Let's
talk about it again, how do I eat, what kind of
car do I drive, do I fly or do
I drive? I think everyone has
issues in their own area and
I try to address all of the ones I mentioned
and be better than the year
before
and a lot of people do that and
I think that's really great and I
also believe that this inner conviction
is the first step for you to
perhaps do even more and
of course the influence of a
company worldwide is much greater than what
I have as an individual
try to avoid plastic, that's
great, but the M the needle if you
can put it like that, yes, that's natural as a
company if we set out
to increase the proportion of recyclates.
Avoiding plastic overall, the impact is
of course significantly greater, the same
applies to saving water for waste
Saving for renewable energies means
reducing the footprint you have
and I see this as one of the important issues we have for us as a family.
You are also pushing your board of directors to
think about it and tackle it actively in some way. Yes,
luckily I need it  not
to push so much but to encourage and
support because,
fortunately, they themselves
have high standards of developing the company in the
direction that we
as Henkel have a great history and
tradition when it comes to sustainability,
as a family but also as a
company, we have had an
environmental report for decades, it was called  Previously today
Sustainability report has been
leading in many ratings and
rankings regarding this topic for many years and
still has high standards for the future if you
think about it and
run a company like that. In the end, as with so
many questions, it is almost better for you  would
n't do it, you would say we do
n't grow any further because any growth
will probably cause uh again
and and so
you still can't really win it, but it would be
best if we
held our breath, exactly there are already so many
extreme ones  W say no more young people
because
yes, that's a possibility or
a
way of thinking for me,
it's for the future we
can't get by without technologies and innovations.
I believe that the solution to
many issues lies in progress and
for me that is also me  I come from the
natural sciences, there's a lot to
come and that will make a lot of things
easier for us than we might
see today and I've also asked myself the question,
should Henkel now say
we have to stop everything, just so
we can certainly reduce our footprint,
that is  Maybe it's the first step,
but that ca
n't be the point of the exercise, so that's not what we
started for. What our goal can be is
to do better than the competition, what
people will always do their
laundry, what can we do to reduce
the CO2 footprint  of washing laundry is
becoming smaller overall and now
I'll go back to that was the example that
I wanted to do again beforehand
if you look at what
the CO2 footprint of this company is then there are
different criteria it
starts with along the
value chain it starts  With the
purchase of raw materials,
something is produced here on site, then there
is logistics until it reaches the retailer or the customer. Fourthly, very
important is the
application phase and fifthly,
disposal afterwards and if you now ask
which of the steps produces how much
CO2  Then one would assume that
production is very important because
here there is smoke from the
chimney stone, but the reality is
completely different. Two thirds of the CO2
production takes place by the consumer
when using our
products and that is the biggest lever for
creating change, the second largest
part  Less than a third is in the
purchase of the raw materials because they
of course had to be manufactured somehow
and come to us there
is also music in it but the
production is less than 5%.  So almost
nothing and of course every
ton of CO2 that we
can save here in production is important and
good, but you have a lot more leverage if
you save CO2 in use if you
and I no longer wash at 60 or 90°
but at a lower temperature
Temperatures when you choose a program
What a savings program is when you
maybe
turn off the shower in between while washing your hair and when it comes to the
topics, I believe that it
is our responsibility to try
to educate consumers too
or to give them this way of thinking
that that's what it is  The important thing is that
you can contribute to it yourself and
of course we can reduce the amount of plastic,
use less overall,
make what is made from recycled material and the like and if you
are better than the competition, I think
you have already made a good contribution,
you are actually one
political person a political
person it works it works I'm glad
that there are politicians who
have really learned this and who are absorbed in it
I wouldn't be a good politician I
think
it's because you need
other skills than I
have and  how many are you quick
to criticize but
do it yourself but swap it out so there are
people in politics with whom you also
have an exchange on the topics of
course politics is extremely important and
it is so important that there is an
exchange between business and
There is politics and science if we
want to tackle the issues of the future,
nothing is more important than
people meeting and exchanging ideas and
planning together what happens next because
everyone has the most knowledge in their area
and only less knowledge in the
other areas and so on  A lot of things that
politicians think about are well-intentioned
but sometimes fail because of the
ability to implement them in the economy
or science says
we are not there yet and conversely
I could say what the economy
wants is not always the right thing, so
it is good that that is
regulation
But that's why such
exchanges are very important for me. A
platform is the donor association, where
I'm a member of the executive board, which is
trying very hard to
keep this exchange between
science and politics, for example, very
lively, even with a new president  and I think that's
extremely important. I'm a
member of the Max Plan
Society myself. For me,
this exchange and direct access to
science is really great because you
're so close to what's happening on the
scientific front and the
exchange  If you want, with
Nobel Prize winners and if there are
events in falling walls in Berlin,
you
probably know who want to do exactly that,
namely to bring business, science and
politics
together because in the end you are responsible
for our, let's say, climatic
situation in the next 10 to 15  20
years at least tend to be more
optimistic than most, or do
you say or how do you look at
that, are you just as pessimistic as many
climate researchers or what can I know, what other
solution can technology and science
give us? I'm seriously
worried because that  What is happening at the moment
can be a cause for concern, I
believe that this
climate change is progressing very quickly and
is becoming visible in many facets,
even here in Germany and there
are planetary boundaries that
have the limits of this planet number
and some of them are about
to be exceeded  and some have
already been exceeded and then there are
already domino effects of tipping points
and then I think it
may actually be beyond our ability
to influence it, that's what
happened, we can prepare ourselves,
we
probably have to do it better if we were so smart
that we are already
initiating things that will prevent the
world from becoming an uninhabitable planet,
it's not about protecting the environment
for the environment, in the end it's
about ensuring that people will still
find conditions worth living in in the future and on
best not only humans but also
plants and animals because it's all
related to each other. I
studied biology. I have a great respect
for the origin of life from the
smallest microorganisms to us. We
can sit here, we can talk, we breathe,
the heart beats  It's
fantastic and I would like that
I would like to be able to preserve that without the
extinction of the species that hurts me
when biodiversity decreases that every
ecological niche has its purpose and
every species that dies out makes the power
worse. We are not allowed to use the
genetic pool here  It doesn't get too tight,
that's why I could talk about it for a long time
and a lot of people are worried,
but I wouldn't be me if I did
n't believe that people have
at least always managed to
pull themselves out of these
difficult,
um, situations that we encounter  So
I believe that
science research and development
can bring a lot of solutions here in the future, but we
also have to tackle it, we can't
waste any time and if I
would like it or if I could, F I would love it,
we would have some kind of sensible
world government because
We can't discuss these topics alone in Düsseldorf or in
Germany because if
the other countries act differently
then you often end up with
competitive disadvantages or
locational disadvantages, so it would
actually be nice if you had
a council of 20 wise people at the top, science,
economy, politics, society  Unite
and make a plan for the
entire planet, what should it look like
because I think there is clearly
the right path scientifically,
you have to make sure that it is
implemented politically sensibly and
economically and socially
feasible, but if there
were an overarching plan  and then
maybe there are people who
make this applicable to regions or countries, then you would have a
longer-term planning and
implementation option that is
actually intended for that purpose, no,
but there
still isn't enough happening because it's small
Small, every government in our country
decides one thing or the other, the
next government is
composed differently and has different
goals and so for me there is often a lack of
continuity. You find that the people
who are now at the top of these
famous lists are there
Bill Gates and Elon Musk and others like that are
also working on it and are now
working very hard on it. Do
you observe it or do you
perhaps even exchange ideas with others who
are out there somehow like they
do it or how they get involved?
Those mentioned are already
excellent, the places don't just
provide money, they build entire
organizations to
really tackle climate change, hunger and other issues. I think
that's great, it's really exemplary and
also
Musk as a personality like he has
achieved it  Actually, as an
individual, really shaking up an entire industry,
that's a great
pioneer because he shows it's possible, but it
may not always meet
all the requirements a it with one or
two authorities, but he shows it is,
it's possible, you can be really
progressive  be and
and affordable to the moon and back or
in space let's say fly and
his other projects that's why
I think it's great to be a pioneer I
think it's great that's
our motto here at the un company
Pioneer for the good of generations  That's
why for me people who demonstrate something like that are
really
exemplary, I think, and but there's
no exchange now, no such thing as any kind of
inspiration, specifically say W or you do
n't meet up with I did
n't meet up with Elon mas not with B Gates
but of course there are
other other larger families
who have a heart for such things
or a head for it and that's
why there is also an
exchange is also important then
maybe pooling forces has changed a lot
since you started the job  improved the situation
of women in business,
that was you started in 2010,
I think so, so it's been a while,
I looked it up, it was a
huge topic,
supervisory board member was spectacular that you
were elected there, I would have now
from today's perspective it wouldn't be  It's no longer
as incredibly spectacular as it
was back then, but luckily my feeling is
absolutely accurate, but as it is, I
would say we're as good today as
we've never been, that's
nice, but of course we could
be a lot better, so it's a mix  my
my assessment of the
situation it is still good, correct and
important when the topic of diversity and that is
an essential factor here is a
woman but of course it goes
beyond being a woman or gender, that's why
diversity is extremely important to promote
and always where you  There are disadvantages,
you have to pay attention to them,
that's certainly the case in Germany,
and that hurts
me too  It's
not enough if a company
says we are now promoting women in
leadership positions but
then society perhaps doesn't
provide kindergartens so that a woman can
take them, which is still the usual role model. You can
say I'm going to work now and my
child is still good
Social recognition is
more advanced in other countries than is the
case here, unfortunately that is
still the case. We are much better now
when I look at the younger generation,
it is much more common for
women to have a career and now
we still have to ensure that  you
really, if you want to do
both, what is your quota at the moment?
I haven't looked, so I do
n't want to see how you
imagine it, for example, so yes, we are
five board members, including one woman, we
are on the
supervisory board. I have to check now,
I think  43% proportion of women is the required number at the
moment. 30 is also
fine. We also received a prize
for it a few years ago.
The topic is on our agenda and
yet we have now decided on gender parity
for leadership positions,
more or less  It was about
2025 and we still have a way to
go. We can't
say otherwise, but that would be a great
signal if you at least get close to it. Okay,
okay, I think I've
now asked everything that I
wrote down  I didn't
ask about former board members who
then changed, I would have been
interested, but I was
afraid that you didn't want to say so much about it
Um, no one was as famous as the
head of Henkel as he was and then became even more
famous afterwards but at the end
it was at least it wasn't that
successful. Yes, I can talk about Henkel at that time.
He came or became
chairman of the board in 2008 and stayed that way until he was 16
8 years, just like his
predecessor and previous predecessors, he
brought a lot of good things here, the
focus on speed and
performance, we urgently needed to
improve the market, that was really
a particularly important topic at the time
and also internationalization, the
topic of women, he already had a lot of
positive things  Contribution made that that
was the case and it also
brought a lot of fresh air to the corporate culture here too but
you are no longer in contact
then write an SMS or a WhatsApp yes
but over the years it
has also changed at Adidas yes  There's enough to do,
you have to say, it's
split up a bit, but you're
no longer in regular contact, but
he wrote a very nice Christmas card
where we're now telling you
the topics where I wasn't quite
sure about a topic that I told you  I also wanted to
ask because you've already
been successful in everything,
somehow probably also
unsatisfactory stock market price for you,
no one can be happy with that, yes, but it was
significantly higher than we're talking
about 10 years ago or SAS
size was almost double  so much
wan li that yes,
I think the stock market price is
relevant, it may
not be so relevant for the family shareholders now because
they said yes, we sell under,
we don't have to be
able to sell the shares every day now, but
of course it's a signal for that  how
external third parties evaluate our company
and its future viability,
which is why it is important that
the share price should reflect this and
at the moment, in my opinion, it is
not where it should be,
but the board of directors sees it the same way and so do
most of the shareholders, which is why
we are working hard for it  that things are
developing in the right direction again. Mr. Knobel
started 2020 with
his as CEO and with his
purposeful growth agenda, which we still
have in place today and which we are also
implementing. Unfortunately, the first three years were
one due to Corona supply chains in Ukraine  Time in which we
couldn't implement what we
actually wanted to implement so quickly, but that's
working now. Fortunately, we've made good progress on many issues in many areas,
for example when it came to
merging our two
consumer areas into one
are
topics that are very positive, there are
further examples of this, what is still
missing is that this
implementation is actually reflected in
financial KPIs because in the end,
what the capital market sees on the surface
is that sales have succeeded in increasing
not only value but also volume
the margin changes and many
other issues that lie underneath and
that takes a bit of time. A
growth strategy wasn't implemented in a
quarter or, for us, not in
a year or two, but
we're on the right track and I
'm very happy about it  I am confident that the
capital market will also see these successes in the near future
and will then
hopefully have more confidence in
the future of the company. What was
the last big innovation that
the company really
came up with something new, and that was the case with you too
Now that we've reached your level,
it's okay, it's great, it's new, she
invented it, that's what it's all about, my
added value is also clear to you now,
growth and internalization and
volume expansion and good marketing
and so on, but in the end you need a
new product, you have to  to
invent something mhm So there are numerous,
many smaller innovations and they are
extremely important and today it is
perhaps a small innovation and
what will become of it will only be known later,
but for example in battery manufacturing it is not
in battery production but for us
we are suppliers  When it comes to
assembling batteries, we are able to implement
the topic of heat
dissipation and
heat management much better with new technology and thereby
increase the durability of the battery
and also improve the performance,
longevity and how many
kilometers the mileage will ultimately be
This is
perhaps still manageable in terms of sales,
but if you imagine that this is
used by a lot of battery manufacturers and car suppliers, then this is
certainly something that will also be a
source of further income for Henkel in the future, which is also
happening all the time in the detergent sector,
which is also for itself  taken only
small because, if you like, every
detergent somehow washes cleanly,
but the provision of
special enzymes that specifically
nibble away this or that stain is
an added value every time. We have now
brought an innovation onto the market
that also makes it possible to use the washing machine
To keep washing even cleaner,
that the very smells that often
arise are microbiological
biofilms, okay, special, I always
like them to form when you do
n't wash too hot so often, then
one or
two microorganisms also feel comfortable and there
In our new Persil we have
now also
accommodated enzymatic options so that something like this does
n't form in the first place or is returned when it
is there and that's why
no bad smells arise. That's
now please don't worry,
it's not something you're talking about
somehow gets sick or otherwise we've had
this topic
on the agenda for a while now it's more like
something maybe K say cosmetic
or
olfactory and is relevant to the longevity
of the washing machine okay okay
so it's moving forward Van Van
go hair coloring techniques we also have
innovations  Well,
something always comes from every corner
and, as I said, how valuable that is, I
think you often only realize later that
everything becomes clear, thank you very much,
thank you
[music]
too